ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns in
unserer kleinen süßen minecraft welt
meine lieben freunde wir dürfen gar
nicht lange zeit verlieren aber ich habe
schaden bekommen wir müssen erst mal
ganz kurz in unsere kisten krippe hier
laufen denn ich benötige eine menge
steine und wir benötigen auch ein
bisschen redstone plus einen glos tonnen
hier habe ich den nämlichen denn ich
habe mir am ende der letzten episode
vergessen noch eine redstone lampe zu
machen auf der einen seite die benötigen
nämlich für den leuchtturm heute und die
steine nehmen wir auch mal direkt mit
hier hinten zu unserer stein säge denn
ich habe mir ebenfalls vergessen noch 30
steinmauern zu machen das 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10
[Musik]
wir haben immer noch diesen bescheuerten
zombie villiger unten in der höhle nun
können wir allerdings mit dem leuchtturm
starten ich mache vorher allerdings noch
mal eben kurz die sachen hier zurück in
die kisten plus was ich mir auch noch
machen wollte war eine neue schaufel
denn ich habe angst dass unsere schaufel
kaputt in wird denn wir benötigen ja
auch wieder eine menge grüßt ressourcen
lte in meinem fall einfach erde und was
sich auch noch mitnehmen wollte war ein
wassereimer denn da wurden in die
kommentare geschrieben luca wenn du wo
habe ich denn hier geht noch gar nicht
so lange lebt schon zwei mal daumen hoch
gezeigt dass zu müssen können channels
daumen hoch zeigen kinder und alte leute
team geworden oder mir würde auf jeden
fall und in die kommentare geschrieben
das sich den ganzen trocken beton den
wir ja hier unten in unserer kiste drin
haben das wie ich denen nicht hier unten
überall hin setzen muss und dann abbauen
und so weiter und so fort
sondern ich kann auch einfach ok ich
muss schnell sein ich kann mir aus dem
trocken beton angeblich auch einfach
einen turm bauen und diesem turm werde
ich dann einfach mit dem wassereimer
bestäuben von der einzel bestäuben ist
das komplett falsche wort wie geil es
von hier aus sieht da hinten wie geht's
perfekter ich muss ich ganz nebenbei
also die ganze sache nur überholen
[Musik]
so die ganzen sachen sind hier vorne auf
jeden fall am staaten unserer doppel
kiste dort hinten befindet sich nichts
mehr unser scharf versucht ja genau
danach sieht es auch aus wir müssen uns
allerdings nun erst mal hier auf diese
ebene konzentrieren denn ich muss die
obersten drei ebenen hier erstmal abtrag
also dass jetzt die erste ebene dass sie
ist die zweite ebene und die darunter
auch noch wenn der leuchtturm wird
tatsächlich ein bisschen größer als
gedacht
wir können von hier dort vorüber gucken
das könne noch alles sehen das hier ist
ja unsere riesige höhlen insel da muss
auch der mops bonner hin wir haben der
wird dieses jahr noch fertig
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde ich habe die
oberen drei ebenen hier abgetragen plus
auch gerade mal diesen großen sport von
uns hier gefällt es musste leider sein
denn der leuchtturm mit wirklich riesig
allerdings pflanzen wir auch hier neue
bäume wir machen das hier unten
demnächst noch ein bisschen schöner so
dass das alles sehr dieses schwert
generell habe ich meine insel noch nie
von hier gesehen wie wunderschön einfach
alles aussieht naja wir dürfen uns gar
nicht lange von ihm was ablenken lassen
meine lieben freunde denn wir haben für
heute wirklich ne menge zu tun
zuallererst müssen wir unsere
materialien richtig vorbereiten etwa
hinaus geht die sonne auf
hier vorne ist alles es fehlt nur noch
diese scheiße der luft zunächst einmal
nehmen wir uns hier unseren kompletten
trocken beton raus sprinten einmal
schnell runter zum wasser nehmen uns
einen wassereimer dem wir benötigen um
den trocken beton zum normalen beton zu
machen und jetzt teste ich mal die
taktik erst mal im kleinen also wir
gehen hier quasi so hoch ich mag hier
vorne mal ein kurzes bin ich wieder
unten gehört davon hier testen also wenn
ich jetzt hier das wasser runter laufen
lasse wird riskiert sich alles
überschwemmt werden
was funktioniert glaube ich dass roter
beton dass auch das auch und das auch
und jetzt
[Musik]
um hat es schon das dritte mal dass ich
ein krönchen daumen hoch gemacht habe
schnelle time labs so freunde da sind
wir ganz oben angekommen ich ziehe mal
kurz mein wasser heime hier wieder so
dass das wasser hier vorne abfließt und
so hoch war ich noch nie in meiner welt
durch noch unsere insel von hier an
heftig dass alles aussieht naja ich habe
auf jeden fall hier noch einiges zu tun
von daher euch nochmal eine ganz ganz
aller kurze kein begleiten so und da
sind wir wieder unten angekommen meine
lieben freunde die blöcke sind hier in
alle richtungen gesprungen weil wir ja
fast 250 blöcke oben in der luft fahren
von daher hier mal ganz kurz eben alles
in sammeln sie noch irgendwas nee was
wir allerdings hier vorne haben bzw ist
es glaube ich schon wieder dies spornt
die ja wir hatten hier eine kleine
situation wieder mit einem typen mit
mistgabeln der uns abgeworfen ich habe
dennoch besiegt habt ihr vielleicht in
der time labs gesehen
allerdings hat er uns leider wieder
keine mit gabel gedruckte und bis das
wasser abgeflossen ist das buch liegt
ziemlich langen die zeit können wir
allerdings ganz kurz nutzung auf diesen
kommentar hier einzugehen und das ist
wirklich die beste idee die seit langem
in den kommentaren gelesen habe es geht
nämlich um unsere tier bzw bauminseln
die ihr dort hinten eingeblendet und
zwar hab ich den kommentar gerade schon
gelesen die könnten wir nämlich einfach
trauminsel nennen dann sage ich nicht
immer tier beziehungsweise baum insel
sondern es gibt hier bisher und baum
herum traum kann das jetzt mal ein
bisschen hier so das wasser abgeflossen
meine lieben freunde von daher hier kurz
der block rhein und die jetzt müssen wir
zunächst einmal die mitte von unserem
platz ihr ausfindig machen ich würde
sagen das ist in etwa hier vorne
vielleicht denn von dort aus müssen wir
jetzt erst mal einen stein zige
reinsetzen und von hier in jede richtung
einige blöcke rüber gehen und zwar
insgesamt fünf stück und in diese
richtungen platzieren wir nun
fichtenstämme und um diese fichtenstämme
rum nun schwein ziegel angeordnet zu
einem kreis bestehend aus fünf stein
ziegen an jeder seite dann hier 1
drei dann wieder 54 13 45 1 2 3 und dann
haben wir hier ein problem das kann man
allerdings ganz schnell lösen nehmen wir
die kiste gefahren einfach abbauen da
wird uns jetzt allerdings eine menge
entgegen kloppen
vielleicht hätte ich mich ein bisschen
besser vorbereiten soll
[Musik]
ihr seht schon ich habe hier ein
bisschen was noch anders gebaut und ich
hab mich zu beginn ein wenig verbaut
leider das muss nämlich eine etage höher
und ich musste noch ein innerer kreis
rhein
ansonsten habe ich das hier so ein
bisschen aufgestockt ich hatte jetzt
nicht noch mehr sand mit allerdings
haben wir noch eine menge sand hinten in
unserer kisten grip also haben wir auch
noch nachholen jetzt konzentrieren uns
allerdings erstmal auf die wand hier ein
bisschen die wird nämlich hier so hoch
gezogen zwei blöcke außer ich hier hier
lassen wir nämlich einen platz frei an
der ecke denn hier kommt eine eisentür
dann und hier vorne eine stein
druckplatte und auf der andern seite
eine fichtenholz druckplatte so dass wir
ganz easy rein und rausgehen können die
steinwand ziehen wir hier jetzt also
einmal komplett rum und auf die
steinwand setzen wir nun unsere stein
ziegel allerdings nur hier hier und hier
dann noch hier vorne zack zack und zack
hier vorne noch eben hier auch wieder
nur drei mit zwei lücken dazwischen bam
und hier auch zack zack und die beiden
denn hier vorne kommen nun schreien
ziegel treppen rein das sieht dann
schlussendlich ein bisschen verspielter
aus und von innen sieht jetzt so aus und
von außen machen wir jetzt auch noch ein
bisschen dekoration denn wir brauchen ja
hier vorne noch einen vernünftig
aussehen den eingang von errichten wir
denn jetzt einfach so zack zack hier auf
die ecken auch noch stein ziegelstein
ziegelstein ziegel und stein ziegel dann
haben wir allerdings noch den polierten
an die 17 setzen indem ich jetzt hier
hin und hier hin und hier jetzt auch
noch mal einen stein ziegel allerdings
die einzige treppe die allerdings
umgekehrt und diese beiden hier gerade
so dass das hier einhergeht mit den
stein ziegel stufen und unter den
steinstufen kommen die stein
ziegelmauern hin und hier dann auch
nochmal ganz normale stein ziegel so
dass wir das hier auch vorne so ein
bisschen eingebaut haben und uns hier
vorne dann einfach so rein bewegen
können jetzt sehen wir hier von außen
auch nochmal stein ziegel um den ganzen
leuchtturm drum
um so dass der von der der kann sogar
stehen bleiben das ist ihr gleich warum
so dass jetzt quasi sich von unten nach
oben so ein bisschen spiegelt also hier
vorne auch rübergezogen jetzt aufpassen
dass ich nicht runterfallen zack zack
zack und hier vorne auch noch 1 2 3 4 5
und hier noch mal eben die drei der hier
war falsch platziert ihr euch noch mal
ganz kurz eben ab allerdings bauen wir
jetzt hier vorne die außenwände hinter
setzen nämlich hier die stein ziegel hin
in dem 3er abstand und hier bzw
im einsatz stand und die polierte an de
sieht und dazwischen steinmauern das
gleiche wiederholen wir jetzt auch hier
vorne auf der rückseite echt ein
bisschen pummelig hier ne mit dem baum
ich glaub ich finde immer ganz kurzen
dann gehe ich auch mal ganz kurz eben
schlafen in die sonne geht schon wieder
unter ich bin meine aufnahmen auch schon
bei einer stunde allerdings habe ich ja
gesagt ich möchte die ganzen folgen so
ein bisschen chronologisch
zusammenhängend haben deswegen jetzt
heute wahrscheinlich wieder eine etwas
längere folge aber ich glaube ihr freut
euch ja auch also hier wieder
deponierten an die sieht hin hier in der
stein ziegelmauer und dort und hier
vorne auch genau das gleiche wie sieht
dann kann der hier leider doch weg noch
mal an dem sid andy sieht und hier auch
stein ziegelstein ziegelstein ziegel
dazwischen wieder die steinmauern und
jetzt auch hier für die seiten das ganze
so angeordnet dann nehme ich hier kommen
auch steinmauern hin hier wieder an de
sieht und stein ziegel das war noch für
die seite hier rechts da auch noch mal
ganz kurz steinmauer steinmauer
steinmauer an der süd und stein ziegel
und auch nochmal auf der anderen seite
es tut mir leid dass die heutige folge
nicht allzu spannend ist ich kann es
verstehen wenn viele sich denken ordne
der bodyguards euro so extrem doof ich
will wieder spannung haben uns so ja ich
weiss allerdings ist dieses
leuchtturmprojekt wirklich schon ein
herzensprojekt in dem ganzen minecraft
ding hier und ich möchte das jetzt
endlich einfach mal durchziehen und
dafür ist die heutige folge dann auch
gedacht nun nutzen wir unsere einzige
treppen und bauen das ganze hier wie
folgt so dass es aussieht als würde die
saturn hier wirklich sich so in den
boden rein schlagen ihr seht schon hier
vorne das passt doch nicht so richtig
das schwebt weil es noch ein bisschen in
der luft die bereits gesagt am ende
machen wir das alles habe ich hier vorne
und zu der seite auch noch mal noch eine
und hier noch eine und dann auf der
seite auch noch mal eins zwei und drei
name dass sie auch fertig meine lieben
freunde bzw
sieht so aus wir auf der einen seite
nicht ob ich hier habe ich mich wieder
ganz kurz verbaut das hier sollen
nämlich ein bisschen anders sein die
muss einmal umgedreht sein und die muss
auch umgedreht sein also so und so dann
haben wir es ich würde ich allerdings
sagen dass ich jetzt für die etwas
bisschen mehr tiefe die ich hier vorne
ein bisschen reinbringen will ich noch
mal ganz kurze time lags ein blender
[Musik]
so haben wir jetzt auf jeden fall ein
bisschen mehr tiefe hier vorne drin das
sieht jetzt nämlich schon so aus als
wird sich der läuft und läuft noch mal
so ein bisschen abheben von dem stein
ziegel gerüst die runden
nun benötigen wir allerdings endlich
unser fichtenholz sie mich eine menge
nicht fichtenholz stufen sondern
fichtenholz falltüren die wir nun habe
ich nicht mehr
die wir nun da vorne drauf setzen werden
die sollen nämlich einmal so drumherum
kommen und dann immer so und so also
diese komplette reihe in eine richtung
+2 noch an der seite bahn und dann eine
wieder so zack zack zack zack zack 1
dann wieder zack zack zack zack zack
zack zack 12 und auch hier bamm bamm
bamm bamm
und dann haben wir hier 1 2 nun können
wir endlich mit dem eigentlichen
hauptthema anfang uns war dem leuchtturm
und dafür benötigen wir jetzt erstmal
nicht mehr diese ganzen steine hier
unten die kann ich mir eben kurz nach
vorne schieben die erde benötige ich
noch so ein bisschen als gerüst denn wir
kümmern uns nun endlich mal um den
trocken beton bzw
mittlerweile ist es ja normal beton
dafür starten wird erstmal mit dem
weißem beton und bauen auf jeder der
vier hauptseiten eine 2 block hohe mauer
und dann in die mitte noch mal drei
weiße blöcke hier fordert ziehen wir das
dann so hoch und bauen das so zur seite
so dass wir dann im endeffekt immer
schmaler werden hier vorne dann wieder
die 2 block hohe mauer zack zack zack
zack hier in der mitte ein 23 hoch und
hier ein 23 und dann auch nach innen das
wiederhole ich jetzt will jeder seite
nun nehmen wir unseren roten beton und
bauen hier einen rahmen für das fenster
nämlich dreimal drei blöcke hoch und in
der mitte mit zwei blöcken frei und in
diesen zwei freien blöcken setzen wir
nun weiße glasscheiben rein darüber eine
fichtenholz falltür und darunter ein
fichtenholz sound vor was wir öffnen
werden dann sich das so ein bisschen
beziehungsweise ich glaube wenn ich das
sound vornehme war klar dass ich jetzt
erst mal das links ab wenn ich das sound
teilnehmer kann ich das jetzt ist es
natürlich auch es ist nicht
runtergefallen sehr gut wenn ich dass
sie gegen platziere dann sieht's
jetzt habe ich komplett so genau so war
es auch vor hinaus und die sonne geht
natürlich selbstverständlich wieder
unter das wiederholen wir jetzt auf
jeden fall an jeder seite von dem
leuchtturm hier vorne zeigt dass noch
öffnen und hier vorne auch beim eingang
des leuchtturms die sache ist mir wird
wirklich schon so ein bisschen übel wenn
ich mich in solchen höhen bewege also es
ist jetzt zwar nicht doch nicht mega
hoch aber wenn ich dann da immer so
darüber nachdenke dass damals in new
york die leute an die an so hochhäusern
gebaut haben das sieht dann plötzlich da
so hunderte meter in der höhe war einsam
sei ich habe hier angst das ist
minecraft ich habe auch wieder einfach
keine bambus gerüstet dabei allerdings
eine menge erde mit der ich mir einfach
so eine treppe nach nebenan setze ich
baue jetzt so ein bisschen weiter mit
dem roten beton das machen wir nämlich
so und dann hier wieder ein kleiner
werden dass sich allerdings ab dass
brauche ich nur provisorisch und dann
wären wir quasi nach oben immer kleiner
also das jetzt quasi auch noch mal
wiederholen für jede seite hier und nun
verbauen wir unseren restlichen
beziehungsweise fast den rest von
unserem ganzen weißem beton und setzten
hier die vierte ebene mittlerweile schon
drauf dafür machen wir das einfach so
dass wir hier an jeder seite fünf blöcke
rüberziehen hiervon auch zack zack zack
zack zack dass die ziehen wir jetzt
alles vier blöcke in die höhe und an den
ecken hier vorne machen wir das jetzt so
dass wir uns zwei blöcke hoch bauen und
dann 1 2 sätzen und 1 2 dann kann ich
mich ganz kurz hier noch mal kurz mit
der erde hoch bauen die ganze erde haben
wir vorhin abtragen können als wir dort
hinten unten alles abgetragen haben und
hier vorne und zack und das machen jetzt
auf jeder seite und nun brauchen wir
doch noch mal unsere fichtenholz sound
hoch und die weißen glasscheiben plus
auch noch mal die fichtenholz falltüren
denn damit müssen wir da oben jetzt auch
noch mal fenster draufsetzen die wir
allerdings schlussendlich genau so bauen
wie die anderen fenster bisher auch also
drei blöcke hoch dann hier die beiden
weißen glasscheiben rein darüber eine
fichtenholz falltür und darunter ein
fichtenholz auch weil ich jetzt immer
zwei richtern shift gedrückt halte das
sieht schon cool aus der ja das ding
wird so riesig nahm die zwischenräume
zwischen den fenstern hier oben ziehen
wir jetzt auch einfach mit roten beton
hoch und hier zwischen machen wir nun
die nächste weiße ebene beziehungsweise
auch schon die letzte weiße beton ebene
die außen blöcke hier trage ich gleich
ab da muss ich mich nur ganz kurz
konzentrieren und da die teile
dransetzen zack zack das soll nämlich
nach innen ein zweiter reingehen so hier
vorne hier vorne und zack zack und hier
der letzte die teile hier kann ich jetzt
auf jeden fall abbauen der kommt weg der
kommt weg der hier vorne kommt auch weg
du kommst du weg und du kommst du weg
ich habe genau den abgebauten nicht weg
sollte dass sie mir auf jeden fall auch
vier blöcke hoch sagt sagt zack so haben
wir das auf jeden fall auch fertig ich
werde jetzt einen waghalsigen sprung da
unten ins wasser machen
das ist zu groß wurde die ich nicht
gedacht aber wenn ich hier hochkommt der
leuchtturm sieht schon richtig nass aus
ich weiß es hier drin noch ein bisschen
beton von mir die tür vorne denn wir
dürfen nämlich überhaupt nichts
verschwenden die sonne geht schon wieder
fast unter ich habe gerade oben nochmal
eine ebene draufgesetzt seht ihr glaube
ich schon einfach in roth noch mal drei
blöcken übereinander und die fenster
genau so gebaut wie hier runter hat aber
das haben eine spitzhacke kaputt
gegangen weil ich mich ein bisschen bei
dem beton wieder verbaut habe ich blende
euch jetzt nicht von jeder seite hier
betreibt sein damit das video noch viel
länger gehen würde mich noch die länger
im schnitt dauern ich hoffe ihr vertraut
mir leid was sie alles mit rechten
dingen zugeht
ich bin schon wieder bei eineinhalb
stunden deswegen konzentrieren wir uns
jetzt endlich mal auf das innere vom
leuchtturm zunächst einmal bauen wir uns
hier unten eine kleine fläche aus erde
hin so dass wir oben rankommen was genau
damit bewirken will seht ihr gleich
schon denn wenn ich hier stehe komme ich
nicht so richtig daran wo ich eigentlich
hin will so allerdings schon denn wir
bauen hier vorne stemmen allerdings von
jeder seite der ist direkt richtig doch
erst richtig platziert hier vorne da
noch einen rüber dann sieht der ist
falsch
der hier vorne auf jeden fall auch noch
kommt er drüber dann ziehen wir den hier
auch bis dorthin
er geht allerdings auch nur bis hier
vorne zeigt dass hier auch noch weiter
rüberziehen allerdings auch nur bis hier
und der hier grenzt dann hier vorne
direkt an den wieder an
hier zwischen setzen wir nun fichtenholz
stufen einfach um so ein bisschen
materialien zu sparen und um dem ganzen
von unten ein bisschen tiefe zu geben
die sonne geht glaube ich schon wieder
unter das will ich aber ganz kurz noch
mal eben fertig kriegen
meine schaufel ist vorhin kaputt
gegangen deswegen muss ich jetzt meine
hand benutzen die sonne ist doch gar
nicht soweit untergegangen deswegen
schaffen die auch das nächste noch mal
ganz kurz was ich mir vorgenommen habe
dafür ich verstehe ich die ganze zeit
bei den kisten dafür benötigen wir
allerdings erst mal einige zäune wo habe
ich die hier vorne sind pflicht neue
zäune und ich benötige laternen zaun
tore habe ich die dabei oder habe ich
die vorne hier irgendwo auch sondern ich
glaube hier habe ich hier vorne perfekt
damit machen wir den ich jetzt ein
bisschen die beleuchtung und dann seht
ihr auch direkt dass das hier vorne ein
bisschen geiler auch schon direkt
aussieht denn ich hier vorne an die
ecken kommen und erst mal fichtenholz
einen sack und pack darunter lassen wir
einige laternen hängen ich finde
laternen so unfassbar schönen minecraft
und dann ziehen wir die fichten
holzzäune hier so durch so ein bisschen
als halterung hier vorne dann noch hier
vorne lang zack hier vorne von der seite
rüber bam und von der seite oder eben
darüber bisher vorne
also wenn man jetzt hier vornherein geht
sieht quasi so aus und in der mitte
kommt jetzt eine wendeltreppe allerdings
muss ich erstmal baden-baden
wahrscheinlich nun können wir allerdings
mit unseren fichtenholz stufen hier die
ecken noch mal eben so ein bisschen
auskleiden bamm bamm bamm bamm bund hier
vorne auch zack zack zack dazwischen
setzen wir ihn jetzt nämlich fichtenholz
falschen ich glaube wir sollten auch
noch schnell hinkriegen bevor die sonne
untergeht generell ist es ja alles
irgendwie so ein wettlauf mit der zeit
ich versuche auf der einen seite dieses
video nicht allzu lang zu halten so dass
wir hier keine halbe stunden folge luca
bauten leuchtturm haben auf der anderen
seite will ich mir allerdings natürlich
auch mühe geben und so viel wie möglich
kommentieren so dass ihr das auch
nachbauen könnte allerdings habe ich
mich natürlich selbstverständlich dass
wir wieder nicht selbst überlegt sondern
euch inspirationen mal wieder und in die
kommentare gepackt beziehungsweise und
in die video beschreibung nicht dort
findet ihr auch mein neues installiert
wurde eingeblendet
ich kann nicht schlafen das
kreditproblem schauen wir es kurz den
sonnenuntergang am krieg ein bisschen
schnappt ihm ein neues instagram porto
wir waren unterwegs auf der alster meine
lieben freunde das ist der see hier in
hamburg
ich habe schlauchboot was schon oft
kaputt gegangen das haben wir allerdings
ein paar mal gepflegt und dann hat es
angefangen zu regnen
deswegen haben uns gedacht wir fahren
hier an den steg an der steg gehörte
irgendwann reichen typen der hat uns
dann angeschlossen allerdings mussten
wir aus dem wasser raus von daher war
alles in ordnung und dann haben wir noch
schnell ein foto gemacht und wurden dann
noch mehr angeschnauzt und daher leicht
das gern die sonne ist jetzt allerdings
untergegangen von der kann ich jetzt
auch endlich mal schlafen gehen sehr
schöner ausblick hier vorne allerdings
erwartet uns nun hier ein wunderschöner
neuer morgen in unserer kleinen süßen
minecraft welt meine lieben freunde wir
begeben uns nun wieder rein in den
leuchtenden wir benötigen glatte
steinstufen stein ziegel und das war's
auch glaube ich schon denn damit bauen
wir jetzt die spiral treppe die
wendeltreppe
keine ahnung feiert ihr wendeltreppen
ich weiß es nicht so ganz ob ich zum
wendeltreppen typ bin ich überlege schon
die ganze zeit ist jetzt steht zwar
nicht im raum aber wenn ich irgendwann
mal eine freundin haben sollte und
vielleicht beginnt oder so überlege ich
auch schon die ganze zeit wie ich das
haus bauen sie jetzt habe ich keine
spitzhacke jetzt muss ich schwimme insel
wollte ich gerade sagen so da sind wir
wieder bei der leuchtturm insel
angekommen freunde und begeben uns nun
ans machen der wendeltreppe sofern ich
richtig gerechnet habe
sollte das von hier aus so hoch gehen
dann kann ich das jetzt von hier aus
einfach starten ihr seht schon unten ich
habe mir zwei neue spitzhacken und auch
zwei neue schaufeln gemacht jetzt muss
ich doch mal ganz kurz nachdenken hier
noch einen hört muss die soße oder ich
mich jetzt schon wieder verbaut ich weiß
es nicht so die da oben muss ja auch
noch weg so war das ja einen runter
gehen soll bzw
das zieht sie wieder nichts für den
kleinen luca um die ecke rum
das funktioniert ja auch das
funktioniert alles interessiert sich
gerechnet nun kümmern wir uns allerdings
um die nächste etage hier vorne dafür
verbinde ich die teile erst mal ganz
kurz mit weißem beton und da vorne
machen wir jetzt sonne hashtag quasi
hier vorne rein und zwar einmalig hier
ein holz hin dass quasi dann zur seite
darüber gezogen hier beim und war der
falsche bahn
den kann man mal ganz kurz eben wieder
abbauen es tut mir leid dass ich mich
hier die ganze zeit so ein bisschen
verbaue allerdings muss ich halt immer
nach rechts gucken da ist das tutorial
hier komme ich jetzt auch gerade auch
nicht so richtig davon so oder wieder
hierhin rüber also wenn man das nach
bonn möchte dann kann ich euch nur den
creative modus empfehlen dass auf jeden
fall deutlich einfacher
allerdings möchte ich an meiner welt
nicht schießen so dass ich mir nicht den
spaß bei der bei einem ganzen spiel
und jetzt hier an der seite rüber bam
und barmen der war auch wieder falsch
ich bin aber auch ein idiot die an die
ecken kommen jetzt auf jeden fall auch
erstmal laternen so dass das hier ein
bisschen beleuchteter ist hier kommen
fichtenholz fallschirm dran hier an die
ecke auch mal eben zack und hier vorne
auch
da kommt natürlich gar keine habe ich
mich dann verbaut und warum die fangen
wir mal eben ganz kurz den hier vorne
bauen jetzt allerdings gehe mal ganz
kurz ab denn von hier geht gleich eine
leiter hoch die benötigen allerdings
erstmal die fichtenholz stufen und
setzten die hier wieder dazwischen um so
ein bisschen tiefer reinzukriegen ihren
die ecken setzen wäre jetzt treppen aus
fichtenholz hier auf der seite hier auf
der seite dann auch hier vorne hier
vorne und beim und beim und dazwischen
setzen wir fichtenholz stufen nun wollen
wir allerdings unsere leiter endlich mal
hoch ins nächste stockwerk dafür geben
wir hier nämlich ganz kurz hoch dürfen
allerdings die leiter natürlich selbst
wahrscheinlich auch nicht vergessen also
jetzt wieder hier hoch praxen intakt
zack zack zack das war jetzt eigentlich
sollte hier vorne der block frei sein so
dass hier die leiter passend hochgeht so
dass er das einmal hier haben und hier
dann quasi die eingangstür ist das also
auf einer ebene ist von daher nehme ich
mal ganz kurz meinen fichtenstamm und
setzte den hier vorne noch mal eben kurz
hin ist allerdings kein großes problem
der rest bleibt bestehen quatsch
der rest auch komplett falsch jetzt
haben wir auf jeden fall richtig hier
noch eine falltür die können wir auch
hier vorne mal eben daran setzen haben
wir das auch hier so ein bisschen
schöner auf jeder seite einfach
wiederholen und hier in die ecken können
wir jetzt auch mal
diese weise wird das gute aussehen ich
weiß es nicht so genau wir können das ja
einfach mal so hinstellen sondern
dazwischen die ganz normalen fichten
heute seine packen dann haben wir die
ecken zumindest auch so ein bisschen
ausgekleidet nun jetzt allerdings hier
oben jetzt erstmal weiter bzw benötigen
wir hier erst mal ein ganz kurzes
geländer so dass nicht von oben nicht
die ganze zeit runter falle also hier
immer kurz rum und hier fehlt mir
natürlich jetzt wieder an
ich bin so schlecht vorbereitet sodass
sound tor ist am start das können wir
ziemlich hierhin packen damit ihr so ein
kleines geländer und nun endlich nach
oben hier ins nächste stockwerk hier
auch erst mal ganz kurz eine falltür
drauf die jetzt einfach dann so
hochklappen können und hier einige
details mit bier kennen nämlich in die
ecken birken holzbretter und dazwischen
ganz normale birkenholz treppen und nun
bauen wir hier die letzte ebene der ist
natürlich direkt ein zu hoch gesetzt
kommen ja niemand ob das ein so erst
richtig gesetzt sagt der ist wieder
falsch zack und sagt den bauen wir mal
ganz kurz ab und ich habe mir extra
gerade genau form einer trauminsel
hinten traum ist schon geil
sonja ich find blick wissen unsere weiß
ich schon geil aus ich habe mir extra
genügend fichtenholz geholten jetzt geht
mir wieder ein blog weil da oben schild
aber gut mit dem rest sollte was auf
jeden fall hinkriegen so soundso hier
vorne jetzt noch einen run der ist
natürlich auch wieder falsch der oben da
fehlt uns jetzt leider auch doch der
kommt nämlich hierhin allerdings habe
ich hat dafür extra ein bisschen erde
mit am start um mich mal ganz kurz eben
hier hoch zu bauen das bringt jetzt gar
nichts allerdings kann ich den ich
derzeit überhaupt nichts gebracht
dies ist die noch nicht längste aufnahme
die ich je gemacht habe in diesem
projekt aber sie wird wahrscheinlich
sehr nah dran computer habe ich nicht
mal dem blog aufgenommen ich kotz gleich
im strahl der letzte block kommt auf
jeden fall hier vorne hin dann haben wir
das auf jeden fall erledigt dazwischen
setzen jetzt auch wieder die fichtenholz
stufen nicht dass ich mich da wieder
verbaut so in die ecken hier vorne auch
eben zack und zack hier geht es dann
wieder hoch das heißt wir benötigen nur
auf der seite noch eine und auf der
seite allerdings dies falsch da komme
ich auch wieder nicht dran
ich bin kurz davor of creative modus
umzustellen
so passt auf jeden fall nun nehmen wir
mal ganz gut so fichtenholz falltüren
platzieren die hier so ein bisschen im
kreis zack zack zack zack zack zack zack
zack zack zack
dann haben wir das da oben kommt es
natürlich auch eine beleuchtung daran
nämlich hier eine laterne und hier vorne
jetzt mache diese tür hier allerdings
gar keinen sinn denn ich kann hier
glaube ich keine leitern weiterbauen
wenn da die fichtenholz falte ist
deswegen mache ich das jetzt mal einfach
so die leitern hier beim bambi vorne
dann weiter mit den stein ziegeln drauf
123 und hier runter und auch hier die
leitern setzen 123 noch einen
allerletzten beim und dann haben wir das
jetzt immer ganz oben
und das ist jetzt quasi der letzte von
dem wir machen allerdings ziehen wir
hier jetzt nicht die stein ziegel nach
oben hoch ihr seht auch gleich warum
denn hier vorne ist die vorderseite des
das leuchtturm machen wir das hier
einfach mal entfernen hier vornehmlich
das fenster denn wie klettern jetzt hier
an der seite des jetzt ist das ding
runter gefallen dass katzen die nicht
ausdenken wir machen das damit ziemlich
hier vorne so ein bisschen zack und
klettern hier an der seite hoch jedoch
einen roten beton hingehen klatschen
wird sich auf jede seite darauf es ist
schon krass wie hoch wir mittlerweile
sind
das ding wird nachher so wild aussehen
wir nehmen jetzt auf jeden fall unseren
polierten an die sie gibt es an die
sieht eigentlich in der richtigen welt
auch es ist gar nicht genau ich weiß
noch früher als ich auf der gamescom war
und so ein mädel die ganz heiß war
maximal mit der unterwegs sie hat uns
gefragt kommt ihr ein feuerzeug haben
bzw
irgendwie kam mir darauf zu sprechen was
feuerzeug auf englisch heißt und ich
habe einfach gesagt flinten stil von
minecraft zweite garde sehen sollte es
noch bei sorry deswegen wir sind
vollidioten aber naja dann muss ich mich
noch daran erinnern also gibt es eine
sieht in real life ich weiß es nicht so
sollte auf jeden fall die decke seien
nämlich auf diesen polierten an die
sieht ist andy sieht ich will es jetzt
wissen es gibt an die sieht und zwar ist
seine gesteinsart und zwar ein
vulkanisches gestein mit mittlerem co2
gehalt sein platonische spellborn doch
ist der theorie noch mal kurz unten hat
mir die restlichen sachen aus der kiste
geholt mir noch mal kurz schlafen
gegangen die sonne steht auch schon hier
vorne
allerdings können wir das ganze projekt
jetzt glaube ich auffällig abschließen
also hier vorne kommende fichtenholz
stufe hin
hier müssen wir nun hier ist noch eine
steinige macht gerade wo sind die denn
hier müssen wir jetzt einzige mauern
hochziehen und hier vorne auch einmal
kurz auf im stehen bleiben jetzt hier
hoch dass sie können wir jetzt schließen
und jetzt hierhin wissen schon echt
ich weiß nicht ob wir vorne auch noch
einen drauf kommen ist jetzt einfach mal
hin allerdings kommt jetzt hier an die
seite erst mal ein wenig glatter stein
so dass wir dann dort drauf unsere
kompletten glatten steinblöcke setzen
können die habe ich mir vorher noch
vorne aus meiner kiste geholt ihr
wahrscheinlich auch vergessen
mitzunehmen
allerdings hatten wir dann noch ein paar
drin hier in unserer kisten kritiker wie
sieht das aus von hierfür einen
geisteskranken ausblick ist so brutal
hier vorne an die ecke kommt nun
allerdings auch noch ein glatter
steinblock zack und hier vorne noch
einer und hier auch und daran befestigen
wir nun unsere schalter die wir hier
haben wir zum hebel heißen sie ja ich
habe generell für ein paar sachen in
minecraft meine eigenen übersetzungen so
hier vorne dann auch noch mal das ich
hier oben so rum sprinte in der höhe
das kann ich auch keinem erzählen zack
und sagt die schalter kommen auch noch
hier an die seite das ist nicht nur aus
dekorativen anlass eigentlich also die
haben überhaupt keinen sinn und zweck
der einzige der hier zu weg hat bin ich
denn ich habe und hier vorne und hier
hier zwischen setzen jetzt unsere
glatten steinstufen nochmal ich hoffe
dass das reichen wird es wieder auf gar
keinen fall reichen
ich habe jetzt nur noch 4 3 2 1 mir
fehlen 3 vorhin habe ich geschafft
darunter zu springen das war wieder sehr
ja ich gehe mal wieder steine holen
das ist echt ziemlich entspannt heute
peter stein
ihre stücke reichen nicht macht nummer
12 das ist es ist wirklich das einzige
was mich heute ein bisschen aufheitern
kann die sache ist auch dass ich bisher
mich noch nicht getraut habe hoch zu
gucken also auch die beiden male wo ich
vorhin schon immer rüber gelaufen bin
war so dass ich was ist denn ich finde
die partie na dann rutschen
ich hab mich auf jeden fall keiner
getraut hoch zu gucken denn das will ich
auf jeden fall zum ende mir belassen die
ansicht mit dem leuchtturm nach vorne
deswegen hier ganz niki mit gesenktem
kopf einmal kurz rein hier vorne
funktioniert alles habe ich früher noch
schon gibt es zusätzlich andere sachen
geholt habe dass auch extrem
und auch wenn man es nicht so richtig
wahrnimmt oder auch wenn wir uns nie in
diesem leuchtturm hier befinden werden
wissen wir zumindest dass es von innen
auch ganz cool aussieht und dass alles
funktioniert so als wenn wir oben auf
jeden fall angekommen die restlichen
steinstufen können wir jetzt für hier
vorne noch benutzen ich glaube die vier
stück hätten doch ausgereicht 1234
na gut die hatten noch ausgereicht
unnötig dass ich mir jetzt hier zwölf
stück gemacht habe allerdings nehmen wir
nun wieder unsere stein ziegel und
setzten die ich hier darauf auf die
roten teile dazwischen auch und außen
rum setzen wir nun unsere eisengitter da
haben wir ja 65 stück am start und die
kommen halt hier auf die schalter drauf
denn das wird dann so aussehen als
würden die schalter also die hebel
unsere eisengitter tragen jetzt nehmen
wir unseren polierten ansieht und
setzten den hier vorne auf die stein
ziegel drauf beim und bahnen das hat
endlich mal geklappt zum glück mit der
anzahl an
blöcken die wir uns davon gemacht haben
hier findet jeder stein siegel drauf
jetzt nehmen wir uns unsere stein ziegel
treppen davon habe ich nur noch 21
spieler ich hoffe dass das ausreichen
wird die setzen wir jetzt nämlich von
außen hier an die teile daran hier vorne
eine dies natürlich selbst erstellte
wieder falsch platziert hier vorne eine
hier hier an den seiten zeigt und sagt
wir haben definitiv davon auch wieder zu
wenig oder es könnte genau passen ich
weiß gerade nicht genau muss ich mal
ganz kurz schauen die hier weg sagt und
jetzt von innen das ganze hier so bauen
damit dass hier so von der seite alles
miteinander connected ist
123 und 123 um ein gottes passgenau die
hier vorne connected sich allerdings
nicht so richtig so okay wir haben noch
eine übrig das hier sieht allerdings so
aus die sache ist die sonne geht unter
mein bett ganz unten also wir hassen
jetzt schnell durch und bauen uns mit
erde mal ganz kurz hier drauf denn wir
bauen nun das glas hier vorne hin dass
gelbe glas und das der leuchtturm
dementsprechend auch gelb leuchtet viele
leuchttürme wurden ja ziemlich vor
ziemlich langer zeit gebaut wo es halt
noch keine vernünftigen beleuchtungs
methoden gab keine irgendwie weil sie
nicht diese modernen leuchttürme die
haben ja auch alle so grelles blaues
licht wie dieser hässlichen richter
ketten immer die sache ist allerdings
dass diese alten leuchten immer deutlich
schöner fände mit diesem gelben licht
und die weißen dann den schiffen den weg
und so wir vorne an die seiten machen
wir leiter war klar dass ich wieder
runter fallen muss ich
der mond geht schon wieder auf die sonne
geht unter wir werden definitiv dich
fertig muss hundertprozentig noch mal
schlafen gehen allerdings hier noch mal
ganz kurz die leitern dran hier und da
ich kotz dich gleich an die spitze
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier bla bla bla bla bla ich brauche
ganz kurz noch mal meine erde denn wir
müssen uns hier mal eben kurz hoch bauen
und hier außenrum netter ziegelmauern
setzen die kommen ich hierhin hier vorne
hin dann auch noch auf der anderen seite
ich bin ein idiot
das kritisiere ich aussehen dass ich
jedes mal darunter falle hier auf jeden
fall noch eine witzige mauern hier vorne
auch und vor den teilen hier brauchen
wir auch noch nett sich um mein gott ich
kann mir einfach hoch bauen die oder ich
dass man vorher gemacht hier vorne
kommen auf jeden fall auch noch welche
hinzu sagt jetzt geht jetzt gerade nicht
hier vorne bamm bamm bamm
und hier vorne an der ecke auch zack
zack zack dort oben drauf platzieren wir
jetzt das dach von unserem leuchtturm in
form von netter ziegel treppen
ich kriege ich die krise
ich kriege ich die krise ich drücke
hierhin warum setzt du dich auf den kopf
nun nehmen wir unsere netter ziegel und
setzten die hier an den rand noch mal
über das glas hier vorne bamm bamm bamm
und nun zwischen wir wieder zurück zu
stein ziegeln und stein ziegel stufen
die steinige kommen hier nämlich so hin
in diesem vier rating angeordnet und die
stufen hier bam bam und bank in der
mitte geht jetzt mal ganz kurz runter
und platziere hier vorne
einen davon denn dort kommt jetzt nicht
unser tageslicht sensor sondern wo ist
denn unsere red sonderbedarf unsere
repsol lampe die kommt nun hier daran
und wird gebaut hat weiß ich und ich
hoffe dieser leuchtturm sieht nachher
gut aus denn sonst möchte ich meinen
kanal mir fehlt jetzt gerade natürlich
selbstverständlich noch eine stein siegl
stufe die werde ich jetzt mal ganz
schnell trafen und hoffen dass das es
mir nicht nachher zum verhängnis wird
hier oben kommt nämlich eine run
dazwischen nun die scheune hier vorne
und jetzt nehmen wir noch unsere reichen
holz falltüren und platzieren die hier
wie folgt nämlich einmal so so ja noch
so und so jetzt müssen wir noch mal ganz
kurz nach oben ich weiß nicht wie wir
dahin kommen allerdings habe ich ja hier
vorne noch die kleine provisorische
treppe du bist unnötig nicht nämlich mal
ganz gut wieder weg dann ist er
allerdings auf dem feld so einmal gab es
eine weiter hoch bauen jetzt noch
schnell die redstone verkabelung und
zwar mir da vorne unsere insel
dementsprechend janne redstone fackel
hin darauf einen tages ich habe keine
ahnung warum das ding jetzt schon an ist
allerdings wer jetzt nicht mehr weil der
tagessatz drauf steht hier vorne jetzt
auf jeden fall redstone hin dazu vision
jetzt nicht roten beton sondern unseren
netter ziegel so angeordnet sagt
dazwischen bzw da draußen
beziehungsweise ich kann gar nicht mehr
reden hier kommen jetzt auf jeden fall
treppen hier
die seiten wo das redstone dransteht
damm und bam und dazwischen nun unsere
beziehungsweise außerhalb davon unsere
leser ziegel stufen die wir noch haben
nun platz den wir hier oben drauf nein
eine netter ziegelmauer und andy näser
ziegelmauer nochmal vier net siegel
treppen normalerweise würden wir jetzt
außen rum auch noch ein bisschen von den
eisengitter davon habe ich aber sogar
noch ein paar allerdings brauchen wir
erstmal das hier zu ende da kommt
nämlich noch einer oben raus da drauf
jetzt auch wieder ein netter ziegel da
muss ich mich jetzt auch mal ganz kurz
eben noch mal eben darauf bauen denn wir
benötigen hierfür noch ein eisengitter
und darauf auch noch eine redstone
fackel die hatte ich ja noch übrig also
ganz kurz die spitzhacke nehmen den hier
abbauen jetzt außen rum noch mal eben
kurz eisengittern ich hoffe das wird
reichen wenn es nicht reicht es ist mir
wirklich einfach scheißegal dann haben
wir halt einfach ein bisschen
eisengitter zu wenig es reicht natürlich
selbstverständlich es reicht auf das
ding genau und damit haben wir den
leuchtturm meine lieben freunde jetzt
auch fertig ich bin extrem stolz auf das
ding egal wie es aussieht es war eine
lange reise ich schon wieder songs typen
ankommt ist und jetzt allerdings auch
egal meine lieben freunde
der erleuchtung den wir so lange
gebraucht haben ich versuche die ganze
zeit zu schinden dass ich jetzt endlich
auch meiner insel angekommen wird sieht
so aus der ist unnormal wild wird
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass der so geil
aussieht und so geil hier reinpasst dass
von hier oben sich die wieder nicht mehr
doch oh mein gott das ist das hat sich
gelohnt
und an der stelle wenn nicht auch das
heutige video freunde was richtiges
deutsch ich glaube ja lasst einfach den
daumen hoch und ein video da abonniert
main kanal und klickt auf die glocke
übermorgen kommt ein neues video um 20
uhr ich muss das ding jetzt einfach
beenden ja der ist unnormal sexy
[Musik]